bảo vệ hoa đồng vận tài quay quyền hóc mút khó khăn hơn đáng kể sau với biển đỏ,
giòn năng lực quân sự và vình chỉ địa lý khỏe ra.
Các chuyên gia cho biết i ran sử của khó bố kỳ đá sản,
gồm tinh lượng mấy mấy thông quay lại và thủ lối,
cồn khả nắng trình khai từ các hôm vận vén biển hiểm trở.
Bây giờ tấm tàu qua iều biển hóc mút phức tà phân nhiều sò mời các trình dịch tru đầy.
Chúng khi đó, các nhà phân tích tru dành,
lượng vế bình kinh mạo hồi giáo i văn của thị trình khai bố khí,
từ khoảng cách gần khiến thử dân phản nướng của lực lượng bảo vệ bị thua hệ.
Mấy và các đồng mình được cho là tâm trình khai lực lượng lượng gông tàu khu chục.
Mấy bây bây và hệ thống không người lấy để bảo vệ tuyến hành hạnh.
Tuy nhiên, theo các trường ra,
ngay cả khi kìm sớt được có mùi đe dọa trên khóc,
mùi cơ từ thủy lối và tàu không người lấy và là mùi đe dọa,
mạm nghĩ trước tình gặp phải ở biển đỏ.
Chúc khi đó, Rồi em khác,
chuyên gia về chiến trích thử đỏng tại vì nó sân nhận định,
việc hôm qua phục khoảng toàn lưu thông của mình hông mô sếp về kiểm tra nhiều tháng,
đồng thời tốt tất cả đỏng đến tìm chương nấu lượng tòn cầu.